[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice george campbell ramsey
personality is my co-host today this is
the ramsay show as we're taking your
questions about your life and your money
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five
two two five so george with a little bit
of traveling um you've been doing the
show more than i have i know dave i mean
first we beat you with the fine print
podcast hitting number one while you
were sitting
far away number two and uh and then
you've been gone and so i've been
hosting with christy with ken and it
felt like you know dad's gone we're
gonna have some fun and now dad's back
and so we're all buttoned up oh so so
you guys weren't behaving or anything
huh well you know we're we're live on
national radio so we we have a filter
still
well
yeah you might christy doesn't we all
had our hair down uh on friday see we
can't do that when i'm here yeah
me and christy can do that that's not
funny we had a great time but hey it's
good to have you back we missed you well
yeah it's not the same without you i can
tell
i saw that tearing in your eye
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five we'll take your
questions the call is free and some say
the advice is worth exactly what you pay
for it again triple eight eight two five
five two two five robertson new york
city hey robert what's up
good afternoon dave how are you guys
better than i deserve brother how can we
help
awesome so dave um
recently i i have a construction company
my father had passed away
um we worked together for many years and
we bought some real estate together
throughout the years uh now i have about
three
thank you i appreciate it um i have
about three properties right now
i think i'm still in baby step two of
paying all my debt because i kind of did
them all out of order according to you
guys
um and i'm just looking to get some
guidance as to where i can kind of pick
up the pieces and what i should do with
this real estate yeah
so you inherited all the property
no we we bought it together we we were
we were partners on it i know but he
when he passed who inherited his half
oh my my mother oh okay okay so you're
making this decision for both you and
your mom
um yes okay that's correct okay all
right cool
well i think um number one we're gonna
put her her needs
at the front of the table before your
needs
okay okay
um but they're probably somewhat equal i
mean it's probably like you know if you
sell a piece of property you pay the
debt some debt on some of your debt with
your half and
she gets some money out of it that
doesn't hurt her you know that kind of a
thing but we're not going to do anything
to harm her and i think that's that's a
given i didn't have to tell you that you
already knew that but we'll just say
that as our first leg in the
decision-making paradigm um and uh how
much debt do you have not counting real
estate
oh maybe ten to twenty thousand dollars
but it's just business debt it's like a
material we buy every month yeah if you
have any money zero dollars
yes yes so you got the money to pay it
off
yes sir okay so you don't sell real
estate to pay it off
no sir okay so what's your plan what can
we help you with
um i was one i have three properties uh
one of them is free and clear two of
them have a mortgage so i guess my
question would be
according to the ramsey method should i
sell one in order to pay off the other
mortgages
and then start again having everything
free and clear because they are income
properties yeah they pay for themselves
plus profit and that's where i get a
little
you know cloudy on the on the ramsey
method yeah well the the ramsey method
is just simply if you are debt-free
you have less risk and you make more
money
so it's not there's no secret to the
rams it's your great grandpa's method
too it used to be called common sense
right and so if you don't have debt you
make more money and you don't have as
much risk so let's just go back to that
now then the question is i love real
estate obviously you and your dad loved
real estate
um and i i um i don't there's nothing on
fire in what you're describing
so but i would develop a plan within a
short number of years to use cash flow
to plow into those two and let us let's
get them paid off and your house get
your home paid off
gotcha now if you want to keep them if
you got one of them you don't really
like anyway and you want to dump it and
spread the equity over onto your house
and
is your mom got dead on her house
uh yes minimal but yes she does all
right and what do you owe on your home
uh about 400 000
okay
well i mean i grew up in the
construction and real estate business
and so there's only one thing i'm sure
of
you can't be sure of anything
right yes and so having a paid for house
a paid for business and paid for
property in the construction business
puts you in a different frame of mind
when you get up in the morning over a
cup of coffee would you agree with that
yes sir so that's a reasonable goal for
you and for your mom so i might if i
were in your shoes i might look over and
pick out the one i like least and let's
liquidate it and uh you know reach over
knock off your mortgage knock off her
mortgage and um then let's you know if
it takes you three years to pay off the
other one cash flow wise fine but don't
look don't just sit there and play with
this debt like it's a your pet monkey or
something let's get rid of it right
yes george you want to jump in here
somewhere yeah i'm feeling that i just
when i look at it through the lens of
financial peace i go what's going to put
mom in the best spot what's going to put
me in the best spot and for me that's
going i want to clean up my personal
debt first including the mortgage if i
can do that and then i'll become a real
estate investor once i'm in a good spot
i've got a good foundation you know
you're investing for the future you've
got that emergency fund in place and
then whatever's left over you can have
fun and play with some real estate at
that point so i like the idea of selling
one of those but i've got a feeling if
you leaned into this if you sold one of
them and kept the other one you could
probably pay it off in what three to
five years
i think if i sold one property dave with
the values here in new york i could
probably pay all that off on every
property and that's what i'm kind of
that's kind of interesting
that's kind of interesting ask yourself
where would you rather be in two years
two years from now
i mean still feeding the monkey or just
be get the monkey off your back i mean
you know it's it's up to you i'm not
i i think you're making plenty of money
and i think you're going to be okay i
the big thing i want you to do is have a
plan to get rid of the debt whether it's
instantaneously or three to five years
okay
got it if you got that then you're
you're on the ramsey plan you're worried
about the ramsey plan who gives a crap
but but then you're on that let me tell
you one last thing okay uh because
losing your dad that you worked with
and y'all built a construction company
in a real estate portfolio together
um you lost your partner you lost your
friend you lost your dad all in one fell
swoop
and what i have told my son and my
daughters is there is nothing that the
ramses own
that you need to keep because of me
okay because sometimes you got well dad
dad said never to sell that i'll dad
wouldn't want us to sell that
you know and i don't want that on you
and i don't want that on my kids
so it's just what is the best thing for
you what is the best thing for your mom
that's what your dad would want yeah and
this stuff can get emotional like you're
saying we took care of last week
grandma would have wanted me to do this
and we've got to make decisions for
ourselves it's written into our estate
plan the operating board is not allowed
to keep sacred cows around here after
i'm gone they should be shot and eaten
i'll take a bite of that
this is the ramsey shop
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
stop paying your overpriced wireless
provider and switch to puretalk they use
the same network as the larger providers
for much less for just 30 a month get
unlimited talk text and six gigs of data
with no contract the average family
saves over 70 a month by switching to
pure top just go to puretalk.com and
enter the promo code ramsey to save 50
off your first month pure talk simply
smarter wireless
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five
two two
five
mike is with us mike is in cincinnati
hey mike welcome to the ramsey show
hi guys thanks for taking my question
sure what's up
so i recently became self-employed in
january of this year and i was curious
as to your advice
uh for self-employed individuals that
are having kind of an outlier good year
and making more than
they would expect to make in a typical
year
how to divide that up between
taking money out of the business leaving
money in the business to operate it
etc
okay what are you doing
i'm an m a consultant
okay
all right
um well i'm guessing you're running an
llc or a sub s right
yes okay so 100 of what you leave in the
business is also taxable as income so
you're not going to avoid taxes with any
of it uh so the only question is just
what kind of liquidity do you want
um
and so mergers and acquisitions have
been a great year and you don't think
that's going to continue
not at the rate that it's going
okay it's been an outrage outlandishly
good year then good for you
congratulations
well thank you
well it doesn't really matter where you
leave the liquidity whether you pile it
into a money market
at home
or whether you pile it into a mutual
fund at home or whether you leave it in
the checking account in the business
it's going to be taxable no matter what
you do with it
but yeah i'm with you i think we carve
off some of it and go uh
we're not gonna go with the mythology of
this continuing exactly as is um
you know we're gonna say okay a normal
year looks like x and anything beyond x
we're gonna try to set back
uh and
you know if it sits there a year or so
we may want to start siphoning off some
of it into some other things but
uh if you did something like pay off
your house with it or you did something
like pay off your debts with it then
there's no loss there in net worth
because you stabilized yourself for
another year the same as the cash would
have stabilized you
okay i think i'm planning to pay off the
rest of our house we do have about 100
000 left in the house but there would
still be some left over unfortunate that
it's a
low cost business to just be a
consultant obviously a services business
right um so there'll be still quite a
bit left over enough to run the business
for several years going forward
so i was planning to leave it all in
there and not take much off the table
aside from that
yeah i i
i would do a i would leave some in there
um
but i'm not gonna leave it in there in
perpetuation at that level
i mean six months of operating is plenty
inside the business
and that's probably not a lot of money
as you're talking you know because you
don't have a lot of overhead right
yes yes so i'm carving the rest of that
off i'm gonna start investing some of it
because you don't want like 200 000
bucks sitting there doing nothing that
didn't need to be there from a liquidity
standpoint and you do need some
liquidity you need some retained
earnings and we recommend since we run
our business debt free our goal has
always been to be at six months of
operating we never get there because we
grow so fast we've grown faster than we
built our savings but that liquidity
makes it operational
yeah i mean if on the personal finance
side i like the idea of walking through
the baby steps and if he can pay off the
house and still have some there and
retained earnings and savings for the
business that's great that's definitely
the the play that sounds like that's
what you're already on and i would go
that direction
james is with us james is in orlando hi
james welcome to the ramsey show
hey guys thanks for taking my call how
are you
better than we deserve what's up
awesome so i am 24 um
and i've been having some conversations
with my employer
and they are
about to offer me a pretty substantial
um
position and a new market
in dallas texas
and i'm going to be going from sales
right now i'm going to be going into a
management and sales role in dallas and
so i'm curious how do i when it comes to
compensation negotiation i know that's
definitely not everything when it comes
to to a job but how do i go about doing
i guess my research
to make sure that the compensation
package that they give me
is
competitive and what it should be for
that area
[Music]
well
first of all what does this look like as
far as this a done deal
is this already happening what's the
conversation's been like so far with hr
yeah it's it's pretty much a done deal
and i was told that i should be seeing
some type of offer letter by
the end of this or next week
okay and you don't have any idea what
it's going to say
i i know the structure
of it but i don't know what the numbers
and figures are going to look like yet
no
well there's a lot of unknowns here
still i might wait on the offer letter
and then you can have that conversation
and you can do some research but again
it's going to vary so much it's hard to
put a number on it especially at 24
years old and you're stepping into this
this new role with a player coach type
uh sales role that you don't have a lot
of experience in i don't know how much
negotiating power you have to you know
get 30 or 40 percent more why do you uh
what is it what kind of business is this
what kind of you're opening a branch
uh yeah it's a
uh it's a commercial contractor
construction contractor okay you ought
to be able to jump online and say okay
running a branch of x number of uh what
do you think you'll run through there in
terms of business 10 million 20 million
2 million what
um
first year if it's just if it's like any
other branch we've opened hopefully
between 8 to 12 okay i would say you
could jump online and say what's a
construction manager of an office making
a run 8-12 top line get paid you
probably can find a comp study somewhere
shouldn't be that hard i mean i'm
guessing google will probably answer
your question i have no idea by the way
what that's worth what do you think it's
worth what do you think they're going to
pay you
man
i wish oh come on i mean you have a
guess what would make you smile real big
uh
75 base
and then you're getting spiffs on
profits or something
yeah yeah that's not a bad gig at 24.
i'm not arguing with that much i do not
know though
i don't think it's worth 250
so i don't think you're getting you know
it might be worth 85 instead of 75 i
don't know
uh and depends on what the spiffs are on
the upside too what percentage of profit
kicks you're going to get that kind of
thing and you know so get guess at what
your actual income's going to be
it sounds like a fun adventure
all the way around because i haven't
heard anything in your conversation or
your voice tone or anything that says
anything negative about these people you
like them you trust them
oh absolutely i just want to make sure i
knew how to do my research correctly
it's kind of more what i was getting at
i'm afraid i'm not much help my you know
when the only answer you can get is
google it you didn't find much help
so i don't know i uh you know the other
thing is there any kind of a
an industry
association that you could tap into in
the in the commercial construction world
that might have some numbers
uh possibly i haven't that i i would
consider that as part of my research
that i haven't done yet yeah you got
anybody's in the business that are
working for competitors
uh
actually yeah i do now ask them
so what should this be you don't have to
ask them what they're making but ask
them what should this be worth
sure
and you know if they come back and go
100 and a quarter and you get 75 then
you probably do have some more research
right
but if they come back to 185 you get 75
then they may not understand your spiff
package
and um you know you can get into it that
way and have a discussion
but um you're smart to not go in blind
but but um i'm sorry i wish i just knew
the perfect website coleman might he's
not here today but um and you can get on
linkedin and try to find people in this
similar industries in your area and get
in touch with them they might be able to
meet with you or just do it over
messages that's so much better than
google thank you
that's an option better answer but if
your only answer is google it means you
don't know anything that's what it means
google knows all when i say go to google
that means i know nothing that's what it
means
you know if you you could have done that
without calling me you know
we're better than google hopefully
on some things obviously not on that so
there you go
it's okay we're still got listeners
that's right
two of them all too okay yeah both of
them but he's gonna be all right he's a
sharp kid 24 years old and already
getting to leadership roles that's
awesome this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today i'm dave ramsey your host
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt free stage brian and amy are with
us hey guys how are you good how are you
how you doing dave welcome welcome good
to have you where do you live
we're from north carolina greensboro
okay cool welcome to nashville and all
the way over here to do a debt-free
scream how much have you paid off we
have paid off 295
578 dollars awesome and how long did
that take five years one month and one
day who's counting
[Laughter]
love it and uh what was your range of
income during that five years we started
off making
76 000 and ended with 138 000. nice
what do you guys do for a living i am a
firefighter and a part-time producer at
a small tv station cool and i'm a
physical therapist all right pt
so i'm guessing five
years
did you pay off your house
no
this was pt bills
yes it was
college bills for both of you a large
amount of it yes yeah how much how much
student loan debt out of the 296
thousand was 278 000 oh almost all of it
oh my gosh
and then we got 17 of it for given two
so
okay how was that forgiven through the
teacher loan forgiveness because i work
for the public school system oh okay all
right that's good so that was the quick
one the short term one yes yeah good
that's the one that's one of the ones
that works not the 10 year plan correct
yeah all right good for you guys so tell
us what happened five years ago you said
that's a lot of student loan debt what
are we gonna do
yes
i graduated from school in the end of
2014 and then we got married in 2015.
and so then the beginning of 2016 i was
like we have to figure something out and
make this work for us and so we
knew about your program through our
friends and so we
decided to do the home study and
followed the plan and started from there
wow
so uh
brian a firefighter looks up and sees a
fire this size
everything's on fire
we call it a big fire big water
it becomes a surrounding drought
operation at that point and uh when you
when you have a big fire you need a lot
of people a lot of personnel a lot of
intensity
and that's pretty much the same that's a
good metaphor for this situation yeah
you guys had to lean in and you had to
stay on in a while i mean five years is
no this isn't a five-month story it's a
five
years i mean in a culture where the
average american can't keep a thought in
their head for eight seconds you stuck
with it for five years i'm so impressed
you guys are heroes yeah how did you how
did you stay focused because a lot of
people they go well i got this much
student loan at almost 300 000 i'm just
going to pay it off till i die i can't
tell you how many times i've heard that
so what made you guys go we're not dying
with this thing and we're not going to
live with it for more than five years
and we've heard that a lot too um that
people say why don't you just wait for
their forgiveness and we were actually
in the forgiveness program for that
ten-year forgiveness
but
my thought proce our thought process was
that
i'm not waiting for the government to
you know there's a lot that can change
in 10 years
and so i just i wasn't relying upon that
but most of it's not good
[Laughter]
during that 10 years
i love that mentality deteriorating up
there at a rapid rate i'm just saying
oh my gosh so you guys drew a line in
the sand where you said all right we're
gonna have to make some changes what
kind of sacrifices did you have to make
over those five years to stay focused
and get this thing knocked out it took a
lot of uh eating at home um luckily my
wife became a wonderful cook
i felt that it was an evolution there
yes
there was a lot of stouffers early on
and then it evolved into some very very
good cooking a lot of leftovers
um it's easy you know during those five
years you talked about it's easy to
get caught up there's those bad days you
know when you get caught up and it's
it's just hard
and you really don't want to there was a
lot of days when i came home and i said
i don't i don't want to do this anymore
and it was it was hard to keep going and
luckily we stuck together as a team i
think that's a lot of what it takes is
sticking together having that team work
sticking to the budget and those habits
your habits are going to propel you
throughout this whole process and i
think that's what's going to propel us
this is just the start
you know from from here on everybody
thinks that this is the finish this is
just the star and the habits and the
rituals that we have created are going
to propel us the rest of our lives
absolutely absolutely because i mean you
have
out of six years of marriage you have
five years and one month of this rhythm
and so you don't know how to do it any
other way really correct and so this is
gonna be i mean just actually going out
to eight's gonna like shock your system
you know so uh congratulations thank you
thank you what do you tell people the
key to getting out of that issue
teamwork uh grit
sacrifice leftovers
and trusting in each other too i mean
it's a team it took a team to get
through it and i couldn't do it without
him yeah and so without you yeah there
was a lot of phone calls about
everything it was it was a budget
meeting probably at least what every
couple days there was a phone call about
something because something always comes
up something always comes up i think and
just being prepared i mean your plans
set us up because there were unexpected
things that did happen in those five
years and it just helped us we had to
pause and move on and
it just
it worked out well i mean we're here
today so yeah well done well done
very cool i'm telling you this
the average american
has a different thought every eight
seconds wow and they stuck with it five
years they're far away from average yeah
now way way forward you guys are just so
resilient i'm just so impressed with the
level of teamwork you guys had from the
get-go and how you guys knocked this out
i mean this is a giant mountain most
people couldn't even fathom paying this
thing off in their lifetime and you guys
decided we're gonna do this while we're
still young and we have life to live and
we have goals to achieve and now you've
got 138 thousand dollars and every cent
of it stays with you yes other than the
uh two of you who are your biggest
cheerleaders
our friends uh shannon and brad well
they came with you yeah yeah she's
actually the one that introduced us to
the program shannon okay
family back home
um a whole county full of firefighters
so well i mean five years you got to
talk about it i mean you got to get
people have to know they either think
you're crazy or they're cheering for you
there's really no in between because
you're going for it it's game on and uh
so financial peace university home study
today it would be through ramsey plus if
you did the same thing and uh
and here you are five years later
296
dollars paid off i'm so impressed
we got a copy of the legacy journey for
you that is definitely the next chapter
in your story that rhythm is going to
carry you out to where you completely
change your whole legacy
very very very well done and of course
uh copy the total money makeover you can
give that to somebody get them started
on their journey so you can pay it
forward there a little bit so thanks you
guys we're so proud of you guys thank
you thank you well done all right it's
brian and amy from north carolina 296
thousand 000
paid off in five years one month in one
day 76 138 000 household income range
count it down let's hear a debt free
scream
three
two one we're
[Music]
[Applause]
let's go
love it game on baby game on
i love it
so good you know i i
it's impressive when people pay off
their debt in five months
or in eight months or whatever and i i'm
happy for anybody that gets out of debt
but there's something special
when somebody sticks with something
five
years yeah
most of you don't even know what you had
to eat last night
they stuck with it that's a marathon
five years that's not a 5k they they
really went for it and what i see is a
couple who grew closer together and i
love seeing that thread through every
debt free scream when you see a couple
who got on the same page it didn't just
change their finances it changed their
marriage
and she became a good cook became
a lot of changes
he was not in trouble it was factual can
you get away with that dave you said
sharon became a good coach sharon just
already was a good cook yes i didn't if
that would not be accurate in my case
she always had oh yeah she can
yeah and i have my body has always shown
the effects
there it is life is good big ol smile
you gotta love it this
is the ramsey show
[Music]
so
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality my
co-host today i'm dave ramsey open
phones at triple eight eight two five
five two two five here on the ramsey
show frank is in venice florida hi frank
welcome to the ramsay show
yes sir you always put a big old smile
on my face mr ramsay well thank you sir
how can we help
i've got a
little home with a pickle
my girlfriend was paralyzed and i
brought potter into my house and had to
gut the house and buy no doors and
put a mother-in-law's feet on the side
for somebody to take care of her and all
this and put a hundred thousand dollars
more in the house and now uh
she got her money and went on which is
fine
and i i'm stuck with a house that's uh
priced at a and tops was 190 in the
neighborhood and i was trying to ask
8289 and i'm not getting any bytes and i
don't know
should i keep it and try to
rent it but with the rent thing i won't
rent it so it's been empty for like two
years and i just
i'm kind of in the in the price of
housing once it goes down it's gonna
mobile homes get hit and you have to pay
cash for it so the this whole thing this
the the addition all of its mobile
home pardon me the the whole deal is a
mobile home i thought you said you did
like an audition
they did yeah yeah yeah
would you attach a different mobile home
to it i don't understand no no no it's
the i bought it that way the carport
area has a huge long carport and they
took that side of it and put up um
another uh mother-in-law suite on the
side
and so the whole structure
is mobile home
you have to walk down two stairs and
then you're down in the other part of
the it's like the ground floor on the
garage level
for the other part of it a basement
so to speak it's the garage i mean
there's there's a garage on the other
side of the door where you can put your
car in or your motorcycle so okay but i
mean this there's not any portion of
this home of this property that is
traditionally stick built it's all uh no
manufactured housing
correct okay that's what i'm trying to
get my head around whatever i can't see
it in my head i'm trying to make sure i
understand okay and and so you think
that the actual market value on it
regardless of what you paid for it if
you put on the market and said i'm going
to sell this to a real person for real
money
the the real market value is what
i had a
lady come out and she said it was
anywhere in the neighborhood
she priced it out for anywhere from 120
to 190.
and uh
it's all wheelchair accessible it has a
deck dock on the water double lot
three huge sheds concrete all the way
around the house everything's macked out
yeah all the furniture goes with it it's
ready to go what kind of water is it on
intercoastal or what
uh fresh water goes up to two lakes okay
all right just access all right
um
and is is there you said it was a
neighborhood or an area that is worth
help in the hundred thousand dollar
range though
well the the the realtor said it goes
anywhere from 120 to 190 in that
neighborhood well that's ridiculous i
mean 120 to 190 why why didn't you say
50 to a million my god i mean i know i
know that's what i i'd like so i think
you need a different
yeah click on elp at ramsey solutions
and get one of our endorsed local
providers out there to look at this
thing
um it sounds to me like it sounds to me
like what you said is true
um that you have
you spent a lot of money to build a
situation
to build a situation out that you're not
going to recoup
right i'm like she'll know where to go
so i got in my house yeah i paid people
trades them to come home i know but
you're well now
i'm not saying you had bad motivation
and that you're not noble you are noble
and you had a wonderful motivation but
the end of the story today is
or the end of the next chapter is
today i'm sitting here with a piece of
property that regardless of how we got
here that we have way too much invested
in based on what it's really worth
yes sir yeah that's what i mean how do i
sell to a handicapped person and then
they would love the house they just have
to find the right person yeah you got
you got to put on the market and it
doesn't necessarily have to be a
handicap just have some have to have
somebody that just really doesn't want
two levels it could be just somebody
doesn't want to climb stairs anymore
right and they like the water
and they like the big garage and the
carport and all that that's all cool you
know
uh and so i i don't care why they like
it i just want them to like it and give
you money for it
right and you're going to lose money
when you do this because you have more
than 120 in it don't you
oh my god
i got over 300 in it yeah so you're that
part's just screwed you understand that
yeah that's why i was asking 289 and
they've had 25 people to do come to the
house it's a beautiful house but it's
it's priced out of the neighborhood
really when it's been 200. i'm like uh
but
you'll never find one like this yeah we
know but yeah but you're priced out of
the neighborhood see what what you what
you paid for it doesn't matter
what you'd like to get for it doesn't
matter what someone what someone will
actually pay you for it is all that
matters that's called market value
right that's what they're saying and
this is this is the part of the story
where you admit that what you did even
though it was of good
intention and a very noble call
cost you 200 grand
what are they supposed to do you know
yeah that's it i'm not i didn't i didn't
say you did anything
but you wrote a check
to be noble
for 200 grand that's the net effect of
this and the sooner you get
past the idea that somehow you're going
to get more money for this because you
were a great guy taking care of her
i'm sorry it doesn't enter into the
equation of market value
there's no part of the real estate
valuation that says great guy yeah and i
don't know how much equity you know
frank's got in this thing or what he
could sell it for what he get out of it
where he's going to go next those are
some pieces of equation he's got to
figure out but the key here is and you
talk about this in financial peace
university in the real estate lesson is
not overbuilding in the neighborhood and
it's for exactly this reason because
you're underwater on it like you would
be with a car and so frank uh i think
you've got some hard decisions to make
but i think this is a stupid tax you've
already lost the money
the only question is are you going to
admit it
that the money's gone
you're not going to get it back out of
this property
and then when you sell it and you get a
check for 125 000
that's when you will admit it
and that's okay there's nothing wrong
with it again i'm not picking on you for
your motives or anything else uh you
know looking back on it you probably
would have done it a different way if i
were to ask you that but completely
understand
well it's the last day of august george
and that means that it is the last day
of our 10
book sale you can get almost all of our
books on sale right now for 10 each
including the total money makeover which
is approaching 10 million in sales so
we've sold a couple of those
uh so ten dollars is a bargain on all of
our best sellers all the ramsey
personalities books are on there uh i
mean just about every single book is on
there for ten dollars and uh our most
popular starter envelope system is on
sale for ten dollars and the ramsey cash
giveaway ends today
enter for a chance to win three thousand
dollars as a grand prize you gotta be 18
or older no purchases necessary text
cash to 33 789 if you want to get on
that 10 sale then what you'll do of
course is go to ramseysolutions.com
and click on
the uh store there and get lined up on
the bargains so george let's just recoup
them a second
two things
and you always want to learn
from these callers uh if you're out
there number one number two um
there's some principles involved okay
number one is uh
when you're in a desperate situation
you seldom make good decisions
there would have been a whole lot of
ways to care for that
lady
his girlfriend
that didn't involve losing two hundred
thousand dollars
uh and but if you get emotional
desperate
uh about how you're gonna take care of
her and he has a big old heart that
guy's got a wonderful heart
um
but you get emotional and that's when i
have done some of the dumbest things
i've ever done with money
is my brain shut down and as you said i
pay stupid tax because i get stupid
so that's thing one thing two is
overbuilding the neighborhood
so if you're putting something on your
house that the only way it makes sense
is you have to be the most expensive
house plus some in the neighborhood to
get your money back out dumb
addition don't do that
number three is mobile homes go down in
value
100 of them
you put those three things together
you got poor frank's mess
and real estate's got zeros on the end
so it hurts even more yeah these are not
small mistakes no it's not a two
thousand dollar problem it's a two
hundred thousand big ole mess ouch
sorry frank this is the ramsey
[Music]
dave here we just launched a brand new
listener survey we want to know what you
think about the show you'll be entered
to win a 100 amazon gift card no
purchase necessary take the survey
ramsey solutions dot com
survey or text survey to 33 789
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king
and the paid off home mortgage has taken
the place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host george
campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today as we answer your
questions about your life and your money
open phones at triple eight eight two
five
five two two five that's triple eight
eight two five
five two two five deanna's in austin
texas hi deanna how are you
i am well sir how are you better than i
deserve what's up
well uh we have an eighteen-year-old
granddaughter that was in a car accident
many years ago and she had started
receiving quarterly checks from the
insurance company when she turned 18.
and she will receive those until she's
21.
and she has come to us asking us
questions about what we think she should
do if anything with that money other
than just putting it in her bank account
i love it
she comes to us because we are debt-free
and
therefore we're able to i think give her
probably a little bit better hopefully a
little bit better advice but since i
really don't have an answer to this i'm
coming to you
absolutely well she's got a good head on
her shoulders because she's actually
asking for advice which is rare from an
18 year old
so i'm impressed yeah is she okay
health-wise
yes she is okay that's good news
so
how much is this quarterly check that
comes in
it is thirty seven hundred dollars
okay and then she will end up
she will end up early around 32 000
somewhere around there by the time she
turns 21. okay that's great and do you
know her plans as far as kind of next
steps for her life is she planning on
going to school is she joining the
workforce
yes she is she actually has a
a little job
and but she will be transitioning out of
that she's going to cosmetology school
which her grandfather and i uh will be
helping to pay for
so her question is
really does she spend part of her money
because we're paying for half of her
cosmetology school
which is the total is about 16 000. so
we're going to pay for half and her
question is should she pay for the other
half with that money or should she go
ahead and
work as much as she can i guess in the
hopes of trying to pay for it which i
don't i don't think she can because
since school is monday through friday
8-5
or should she try to borrow that money
to complete the other house well i'll
tell you one option that is off the
table and that is borrowing money the
first two the first two are fine i mean
i like her continuing to work and if she
can't cashflow it i mean these quarterly
checks are going to do it for her and so
i i see no problem with her using that
to cash flow cosmetology school get on
her feet i assume after that she's going
to live on her own after cosmetology
school is she at home right now she is
at home she lives with her mom and our
hope is that she will move out onto her
own at that point and that she completes
school once she's when she's out of
school and has a job in cosmetology
yeah okay well she's what i would do is
cashflow this thing and there's really
three things you can do with money you
can spend it you can save it and you can
give it and so
i love her really learning how to be
generous at a young age and i love her
having some fun
because she's 18 and she needs to have a
life and go out with friends and do all
the things 18 year olds should do and
she should absolutely save a bunch in an
emergency fund and she can start
investing as soon as she's in the
workforce which is not going to be a
long ways away from now does she have
any debt
she has no debt okay
yeah i agree with george let's just let
her pay for her half through work and
some of this money the rest of the money
is left for her to kick off her life
with
and that might include buying a home
later it certainly will include having
her emergency fund out there and the
whole plan is the way people get into
debt is they just don't think
about other ways to do it and so they
just go sign up and so when she gets she
got a car
she does not have a car as of yet but
that's also something that her
grandfather and i had told we told her
we would help with so part of this part
of this money will most likely go
towards toward helping her purchase a
car at some point cash on the car cash
on the cost of holiday cosmetology
school graduates with still cash in the
bank
and uh starts her life debt-free with a
decent car and a you know a license to
to practice cosmetology and here we go
game on right
game on that all sounds very exciting to
me i like it i'll do it
execute george is giving good advice ah
james is with us in phoenix hey james
welcome to the ramsay show
hi dave truly an honor to speak with you
you too what's up
well my wife and i are 60 now and so
we've really you've been an inspiration
to us in so many ways and so we had two
cars that we got paid off so we have no
car payments
we've just refinanced our house and we
dropped it two whole points down to
1.875 great on a 30-year note i did that
on purpose so that if something happened
because we are older that i'd have a
cushion
so that's really helped us
but our question is is you know the
housing market has just exploded out
here anyway in phoenix and so we now
find ourselves with about 230 000 in
equity
so we're wondering you know like i would
love to get my hands on that equity
because it's not my money till it until
it's my money
so if the market were to crash then i'd
be back to wherever we were
so our question is is how in your
opinion how do we draw out
that equity and not put ourselves in way
more debt again you know
because we're in a really good spot no
credit card debt
so really it's just a house and we pay
200 extra every week on the principal
well you you don't draw out equity you
get equity when you sell the house
or you have equity in the house and you
live there
but there's no there's no way you get
money there's no way you get money out
of the house without borrowing i mean
you could go refinance your mortgage and
run the mortgage all the way up but i'm
not gonna tell you to do that you knew
that
yeah
we're just we're just really considered
concerned for our twilight years and you
know that's about the only thing that we
have
that we can look forward to i have a
small 401k um nothing really to brag
about um got you know about 25 000 as a
reserve emergency fund in cash that's
good but other than that we don't have
anything you got your first three baby
steps done are y'all still working
oh yeah i don't think i'll ever retire
okay then just let's you're on baby step
four let's start chunking money on that
uh into that retirement fifteen percent
of your income going into there you do
that for five or ten years you're 60
that puts you at 65 or 70 you're going
to have increased your 401 k
substantially by then on your roth iras
now where do you think that the best
benefit would be should we stop paying
the 200 extra in weekly and principal
payments to the house and put it towards
retirement or continue to pay the house
down
and use that as our dude you got five to
seven you got five to ten years
to get the house paid off and build a
nest egg
yeah cause our goal is to have the house
paid off in ten years yeah so baby steps
baby step four is 15 of your income
going into retirement
fives kids college that's not in place
six is pay off the house early and if
you want a good solid retirement you
have a paid for house and a nest egg and
you've got 10 years to do that so you
need to aim at that and it's not going
to be 200 a month extra it's going to be
more than that it's going to be 15
you'll be putting at least 15 of your
income into retirement and chunking
money big time on that mortgage get that
stinking mortgage paid off man
and then build your nest egg up even
bigger
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners we're
intentional about choosing the best
advertisers to recommend blinds.com is
no exception they offer high quality
window treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering free shipping and a
guaranteed perfect fit go to blinds.com
and take advantage of this week's
special savings
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
george campbell is our
co-host today ramsey personality and
nathan is with us in san antonio hi
nathan how are you
hi dave and george thanks for taking my
call sure what's up
uh so basically i'm i'm 23 i've been
living at home with my parents for the
last six or seven months since i
graduated college
and i've basically just been saving
money because i know i knew ahead of
time that my job was going to help me
relocate
and i am relocating in the next week and
i've been planning for that and i have
um
a beefier emergency fund than a thousand
dollars
um not that much only about ten thousand
dollars but um
i'm basically was planning on using that
to move with um
and the one thing my parents were
helping me out with was my car insurance
and um
just yesterday they kind of uh dropped
it on me that they want me to take over
that well before expected um i was
planning to pick that up a bit down the
road after this policy like expires and
we have to renew it um but i've budgeted
all my expenses with my income and
uh like i could easily do it it's just a
matter of
um i feel like they're kind of like
dropping this on me at the last minute
and it's not something i've really
factored into
what i'm going to be doing over the next
few months and it's just so short notice
that i i don't know if i should just do
it
to make them happy because um
they kind of gave me an ultimatum about
it that if i don't do it then they're
not gonna
they'll drop me from the insurance or
i'll i'll have to leave the truck uh
here at my house which is not really
feasible um so i just kind of wanted to
do y'all's advice somewhere
so what is what's the insurance cost is
this like a large expense
i mean it's it's going to be like 250
to 300 a month um but basically you know
i've already done my uh zero-based
budget on every dollar and it's just not
something that i factored in and i could
easily just pay like the
the full six months sum um up front um
and take the hit on my
um
as like a moving expense i guess um
but yeah it just caused like unnecessary
function at the last minute and how much
is your truck worth
my truck is worth about
uh i would say a little less than
fifteen thousand what do you owe on it i
said
i owe 3500 okay and what is the uh and
you have ten thousand dollars in savings
and and how much are you making at the
new job
i'm making right now no at the new job
when you move
right well i'm kind of working the new
job right now it's just been work from
home but now that i'm relocating it's
actually going to be the same pay but
i'm getting a raise in april right now
it's 35 and in april it'll be 45. that's
good okay nice raise
all right um
it sounds like this is more relational i
feel your frustration towards your
parents more than it is the actual
amount of the insurance
yeah that's definitely that definitely
played a role um we talked about it
yesterday and
uh it's just
they they just see like how much kind of
like stress it's all causing me this
move um it is like from where i am now
to florida which is like halfway across
the country and
um
i don't know i really don't know what it
is i think they feel like i'm somehow
a big liability because of the far drive
that i'm taking
um and they just kind of like
hit me with this when we've been talking
for a while that no i think they i think
they finally got you off the payroll and
they looked up and went hey we can get
rid of the insurance too
i don't think they look at you as a
liability i don't think they're trying
to crash your little boat i think you're
going to be fine
they just they just want to cut the
apron strings that's all they're doing
uh and i agree i agree they're a little
bit uh rough about it because it could
have given you more of an emotional
on-ramp or a mathematical on-ramp to try
to uh to catch up i'm not disagreeing
with you on on that idea nathan but um
so here's what i would do i would go to
ramseysolutions.com and click on elp for
insurance
have one of our elps shop your car
insurance and get the best possible deal
i think you might be over paying at 3
000 a year even at 23
for a 15 000 truck that seems a little
rich to me
i might be wrong but let them shop it
for me okay
then when they shop it you can put a car
insurance on a monthly as you know and
if it's 250 a month put it on the 250 a
month
and just tighten your little every
dollar budget up and make it work and if
you got to work an extra job a little
bit you got to work an extra job a
little bit it's just a little it's not a
a devastating blow but it's heavy enough
weight that they dropped on you suddenly
that it knocked you back on your heels a
little bit george is right this is more
emotional than it is mathematical but
it's heavy enough that you felt it
right yeah exactly yeah so but you can
you can do it and you're going to be
glad you did it and i don't think
they're out to get you i don't think
there's any malice in this at all i
think they just didn't do a good job of
cutting the apron strings they used a
machete instead of a scalpel
right right yeah
a blood instrument you know it's like
they just didn't they just didn't give
you good you know they should have said
this six months ago dude you're moving
out and you're taking all of your crap
with you which includes the insurance
and the soccer trophies okay you're
you're out of here we want the bedroom
i'm putting a pool table in there i mean
they need to tell you what's up right
and so um yeah you're making the car
you're making the truck payments right
on your own or are they doing that
well they did for a while and then after
um i would say
a couple years ago basically i'm just
paying them and they're they're kind of
like paying for me um and i have like 3
500 left yeah so when you get moved and
get settled if you've got 3 500 left pay
the truck off that day
yeah that's what i'm looking to do and
they kind of know that i've been um
binge watching your show and then i'm
like kind of laid out my death snowball
i do have some student loans yeah um so
this is a 3 000 offset so you can use
the truck and deliver uber at night or
pizzas at night or you can pick up a job
cutting grass on the weekends and you'll
have an extra six thousand bucks in no
time and it'll offset anything and then
by the time april comes around you're
gonna be okay you're gonna be in great
shape you're gonna get the ten thousand
dollar raise everything's rocking on
you're gonna be just fine it's just it
just it just was heavy enough and it was
sudden enough that it caught you
and so it's it's it's a you know 20
math problem 80 percent relational
emotional problem yeah right and part of
it is adulting adulting just sucks and
when you're leaving your
early 20s and you start going oh crap i
have to pay for insurance no one told me
how expensive this was yeah you start to
just kind of feel like you got punched
in the face a little bit uh so i think
once you get on your feet and you get
out on your own you've got a good income
you clean up the debt yeah those
payments are gone you're gonna have that
income back in your life and you're
gonna go okay i can breathe a little bit
amy is on the line she's in atlanta hi
amy welcome to the ramsey show
hey mr dave how are you good what's up
hey
dave my son is 22 and he had he bought
some land um before the market went up
and now he's selling to land and he's
going to end up with about 25 000
um
where where
should i help him to put that money
we talked about what they call the um
like kind account where he just holds it
to move it into another real estate in
case he buys some more real estate but
i don't think right now he's going to do
that because the real estate is so high
right now
yeah if he does a 1031
tax referral exchange which is what
you're referring to is six months to
select the real estate so if he's not
going to buy a piece of real estate in
six months he's just gonna cash this out
and pay it's gonna the capital gains on
it's only gonna be like three grand
okay if he makes twenty thousand dollars
he made twenty thousand dollars profit
yeah does he own it a year no
no no he made ten thousand dollars
profit oh ten profit okay has he owned
it a year
um yeah okay that is fifteen hundred
bucks
fifteen percent on your profit yeah so
just pay
pay the tax don't worry about it and do
something smart with that profit um
he should he's 22 he's out there buying
land he's already got this stuff on the
run yeah and as long as he's debt free i
don't know his financial situation but i
want to make sure that he's following
the baby steps and that he's doing
things that are right for his financial
future not getting into investing too
early in the real estate business yep
that's it that's how it works
[Music]
parents uh when you're going to cut them
loose and you should
uh gradual is good
sudden is hard for them
it's easy for you but it's hard for them
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt-free stage jared and gabby are with
us hey guys how are you good
how are you welcome welcome where do you
guys live omaha nebraska a bit of a hall
to nashville oh my goodness well welcome
good to have you and all the way here to
do a debt-free scream how much have you
paid off uh we paid off 94 000 in 28
months good for you and your range of
income during that time
is it a 110 to 138 cool what do y'all do
for a living
i'm a carpenter for a commercial
construction company
and i'm a technical recruiter ah very
good very good cool well goodness
gracious 94 028
months how long you two been married
we've been
married for a little over two years high
school sweetheart so we've been together
for over 10 years okay cool so even
before marriage you guys started looking
at this going we got to clean this up
and then first order of business and
marriage is finish up the debt snowball
yep absolutely so tell us the story how
did this all happen yeah so we were
taking our pre-marriage counseling at
our church and we were getting involved
in a couple of different you know life
groups and our pastor recommended
financial peace university um we like
knew the name but didn't really have
anybody close to us that was following
so we were like let's go ahead first we
had a another couple that was getting
married at the same time as us um
go in with us so
we dove right in there we go just like
that yep so you kind of wander in not
knowing what to expect
yeah like so after the first lesson what
was happening
people were cutting out credit cards we
were like okay what are we doing so what
have we gotten into are they gonna where
are they gonna hand out snakes what's up
here yeah is it a cult what are we doing
yeah
[Laughter]
so after the second lesson what were you
doing
cutting them up you too
you too on board just like that we were
on board assimilate to the cult it's
easier that way yeah
wow careful george come on all right
george what kind of debt was this
uh it was uh car loans student loans and
credit cards how old are you two i am 27
27 all right wow so you're just kind of
normal
normal single people with car loans
student loans and credit cards yep and
uh enter pre-marriage counseling and
then you uh get you you go in and go i
don't know and they turn on the videos
and you're going well these people just
cut up all their credit and then the
second time you cut up all your credit
cards
oh my gosh wow kind of a kind of a slam
wasn't it yeah a little bit of a fire
hose when you went up to a water
fountain to get a drink yep absolutely
yeah all right cool
but but you did it i mean you stuck with
it for 28 months pure huh we did it yeah
we were
at the beginning yeah i mean like this
is crazy what are we doing the pandemic
hit it kind of helped with i mean we
couldn't do anything right like oh yeah
our income was kind of affected i picked
up a second job he was you know working
side projects to get the get the thing
done we wanted to come out of the
pandemic and be able to travel you know
we're thankful we're here we haven't
taken a vacation since pandemic so oh
wow
thank you so much i'm afraid you and
everybody else is on lower broad down
there at the honky tonks oh my god i
never saw so many people in my life this
time this town is exploding
two days of that was enough for us one
day one minute of that is enough but
yeah oh my gosh wow well congratulations
you guys okay so
you're 27 years old you've been married
22 months
what advice do you have to somebody out
there that's you
two years ago three years ago
and they go i don't know man this stuff
is a weird sound today but everybody
seems to be excited so what's the key
to getting out of debt
i think the key is just stick to your
budget stay consistent
yeah i mean it's going to be tough for
sure you're going to have to you know
decline going to dinner with friends and
doing all these things but
now looking back it's just like the
financial freedom is important to us
like we wanted to go into marriage
you know work hard and when we start
having a family was important to us
before we have kids we want to get out
of debt so that's kind of the goal wow
yeah a lot of young couples that are
your age are going well dave i don't
want to miss out on life i'm in my 20s
this is my prime you want me to make all
these sacrifices
but you guys are saying hey we're going
to sacrifice for a short period of time
28 months so that we can live the next
20 30 40 with no payments exactly
totally that's a huge paradigm shift was
it worth it so worth it very worth it
all right you're going to go back in
debt
never never
she got the whole rest of your life yeah
no debt
that's a long time that's cool
that's pretty cool because you're in
your prime according to george according
27 well for you it's it's 60. yeah
that's when you're at your best that's
it yeah come on but these guys they're
look young bright-eyed bushy-tailed
they're ready to face the world and they
don't have any payments to show for it
they have a great income 27 years old
yeah really this is pretty cool and more
than anything else uh you've learned to
work together right
so tell me about the big fight
what was the big fight
they're looking at
going
each
other
us did we have one
i don't yeah i don't think we had them
there wasn't one huh nope oh sure you
thought i knew something i didn't know
something they're just nicer in nebraska
they don't fight over there
that's what it is
they're midwesterners they're not
hillbillies yeah i get it okay so day
one you guys decided hey we're on the
same page let's go do this thing so you
really didn't have a big fight you never
argued about it not really i mean we
were really both kind of on the same
page i mean we took the first class and
we were just like sucked in and we were
like we want to do this and i mean we
would have little fights like you know
my amazon packages and he's like knock
it off and you know maybe those
things but there we go
it's front porch litter it's playing
this is a problem yeah no problem knock
it off oh my god i like that i can only
hide them so many times when i work from
home the brain catches them so wow
guys and he's delivering it
delivered to the backyard he needs a
t-shirt he says knock it off prime
yeah speaking of living in prime yeah
all right i love it that's good i like
that thank you for being real you guys
are fun really proud of you who are your
biggest cheerleaders uh i'd have to say
each other
and then who friends and family were
super supportive um neither of our moms
and dads were they good with money and
they so this is like natural for you or
this is like change this has changed
like i think we both kind of just
thought like you always live with debt
you know you always have a car payment
or you always have these things so i
mean our family's been super supportive
and we've been you know helping friends
kind of get on board and you know we
have people reach out to us once we
announced that we paid off our debt
they're like what the heck you know how
did you do that and so it's kind of fun
to just share and
yeah get people on board yeah testify
huh yeah i like it very good good for
you guys well done well we're proud of
you i can tell you that touchdown what a
great young couple what a great way to
start absolute heroes yeah people can
take control of their own lives at any
age or heroes very well done thank you
very much we got a copy of the legacy
journey for you because that is the next
chapter in your story for sure you'll be
baby steps millionaires before you know
it and change your whole legacy and
we're going to give you an extra copy of
the total money makeover to give away to
one of those friends that is saying what
the heck yeah i want to know what this
is do this right here don't do anything
i'll do this right here that's it and
financial peace university that's the
thing very cool all right jared and
gabby omaha nebraska 94 000 paid off in
28 months making 110 to 138 count it
down let's hear a debt-free scream
three two one we're debt-free
well done well done well done i love it
congratulations you guys
great work
great work all right you guys want to do
that
so here's the deal
today is the last day
of the 30
off special we've been running on a
ramsey plus membership for a year now
why does that matter well financial
peace university is one of the many
things you get in a ramsey plus
membership
it's like if you want to see tiger king
you got to sign up for netflix right
that's it's a you know you got it it's
where it's where it is you know it's
that's the deal so if you want to go
through financial peace university do
what they just did you do it at ramsey
plus
and that also includes the premium
version of our world-class budgeting
tool every dollar to help you put that
plan into action take control of your
money and it's 30 off a 12-month
membership or if you don't really know
what you want to do today that's okay
you can even do a free trial
if you want to do that you can do that
so text
trial to 33 789 and learn all about
ramsey plus learn all about financial
future university do what they just did
text trial two three three
seven
eight nine
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today he is the host of the
podcast that had millions of listeners
called borrowed future
and then we launched a new one that is
at even
better success it's going crazy called
the fine
print
and uh well you know the old saying you
need to read the fine print well george
is helping you where different
industries are pretty much putting the
screws to you and uh we're you are
exposing that that's the goal i mean a
lot of hidden truths out there keeping
people broke and you get calls about
this stuff all the time people go dave i
didn't know no one told me that i was
going to get screwed on this and so
every other week we're covering new
topics we just released one yesterday on
buy now pay later remember the old
school installment plans well now it's
all real modern and right below the add
to cart button there's they've got this
thing that says hey what if you paid a
fourth of that today yeah and pay the
rest later and the firm just struck up a
partnership with amazon no and so that
1.7 trillion dollar company is about to
be a gazillion dollar company thanks to
a firm because guess what when you see
the payment is actually a quarter of
what it would have been in the cart you
go oh i can add some more
i can add something you add it all up
it's pretty much like rent to own yeah
what's what's the effective interest
rate on that crap they've all got
different ones different interests
different fees uh a firm's got simple
interest so that's what they're they're
real proud of that they don't have
compounding interest and it can be from
zero to 30 percent
i'm betting closer to 30. yeah
so you can get absolutely pretty simple
people you can't pay for it don't buy it
i won't affirm you using this yeah
so we we talked to uh nathan hamilton
from the ascend who did a
survey on this 1800 people
we talked to someone who spent ten
thousand dollars on buy now pay later
this girl peyton who uh went into a lot
of debt for lulu lemon she's a big
lululemon fan and of course we talked to
rachel two thousand dollars worth of
lululemon for clothes
2200 of her uh thirty two hundred jesus
went to debt unbelievable yeah so we're
talking to people who got screwed we're
talking to experts like rachel cruz who
really help us unpack why these services
are not in your best interest these
companies are not your friend and you
should not use it we want you to pay
cash we want you to buy things so let's
afford 10 episodes of the fine print how
many have come out as of today we've got
uh this is the fourth one fourth one
that came out today okay so season one
is ten episodes all kinds of different
subjects but all about areas where you
are getting uh messed over and pretty
much explains it all to you in
detail
alana is with us in chicago hi alana how
are you
hey i'm good how are you better than i
deserve what's up
so i just graduated college in may and i
worked multiple jobs throughout college
so i'm actually in a position where
i can pay off all of my student loans
but i'm
just kind of stuck because the loans are
in deferment through january so
i would like to get into investing but
obviously that's borrowed money that's
allocated for my loans but i'm just kind
of curious what you think i should do in
the meantime between now and january
um while i have this money
so you're saying you have the money in
cash to pay off all of your student
loans today
yeah
well that's a great place to be uh i
like that a lot and you're saying should
i hold off in order to start investing
well i'm wondering if i should put
if i don't know if it's smart to put a
portion of that while i have cash into
investing or
pay off my debt and then
you know
then consider investing yeah well we
teach the baby steps and this is the
plan that works and a lot of people want
to do them out of order and i think
you're wanting to make the right
decision here with your money and i know
january's going to come and you're like
should i just wait and pay it off then
but here's the thing if you follow the
baby steps we teach that you pay off all
of your debt in baby step 2 using the
debt snowball and is this all your all
your debt just the student loans
okay so you could be done with baby step
two today
uh which then you'd move on to baby step
three building your your fully funded
emergency fund which i like as you head
out into your adult life now that you've
graduated and so i want you to pay off
that debt as soon as possible and if you
have the cash to do that today well
you're going to have plenty of time to
invest you just graduated you're going
to be a multi-millionaire if you follow
these steps so i'm not as worried about
investing as i am about this debt that's
hanging over your life right now and i
don't want you to wait on the government
i don't want you to wait on anyone when
you can take control and you have the
cash in your bank today alana how old
are you
22. excellent what's your degree in
uh packaging science
say again
packaging science wow packaging science
did i hear that right
fascinating
okay so have you got have you landed a
job
yeah i started in june so i've been
working for a few months now great what
do you make
uh 70. well done amazing job that's a
great job coming out of 22.
you really got a really good start
okay here's the trick
inside of every one of us it is human
nature
to want a shortcut
with money you need to fight that beast
that says you can do a shortcut
there is no good shortcuts with money
it's common sense
it's a slog it's a grind
and you become wealthy
if you try to do shortcuts you get
setbacks
shortcuts equal setbacks and that that
beast that looks for shortcuts that's
the one that's asking the question down
inside of you and that's just normal
you're not doing anything wrong
okay it's just normal to ask that
question is there something some way i
should try to move these shells and hide
the p
but no matter how many times you move
those shells that stinking student loan
is still laying there
unless you just write a check and pay it
off you got it
so the cleanliness the cleanliness of
your life
the risk lowered you make 70 000 you
don't have a debt in the world now you
can really be a rock star investor you
can really start filling up that 401k
that roth ira starts saving for a house
start doing some other stuff because
you've got no black cloud hanging over
your head so here's the instruction
listen carefully
pay the student loan off
today
before the close of business when you
hang up the phone
pay off the student loan okay
absolutely can i ask the follow-up
question you can
is it wise to then after that's paid off
to
max out my retirement
uh i would put it at 15
of your income
and then i would start saving for a
house above that and make sure you have
an emergency fund of three to six months
of expenses you're gonna have some money
left over after you pay off the student
loan
yeah okay how much
uh about five grand good okay before you
start your retirement let's build that
up to a full rainy day fund three to six
months of expenses so probably want that
to be about 15 grand so if you have 15
000 cash that you never touch for
anything except big time emergencies
and you have no debt
you are in the driver's seat to rock and
roll
then you start putting 15 of your income
into retirement and i'm thinking you're
probably a millionaire by 35.
that's if you do this okay that's where
i think you're headed so you hold on i
want to help you do it because i want to
hear your story when you're 35 i'm still
going to be here doing this
so um i'm going to send you a copy of
the book the total money makeover and
show you exactly what george is talking
about those baby steps things and
exactly how to do them and exactly why
to do them and uh because i think you're
actually going to do this it sounds like
in your voice you're actually going to
do it sometimes we give people advice
they're like yeah yeah yeah yeah and we
can tell they're not going to do it so
but you you're actually going to go do
this and then if you follow all the way
through you really are gonna be a
millionaire
you really are because if you're making
70 at 22 you're gonna be making 150 at
27.
this is where you're headed
because people that think as clearly as
you think that's what they do you've
done a very good job setting your life
up i'm so proud of you hold on kelly
i'll pick up and we're going to give you
a copy of the total money makeover
there's hope george
there's 22 year olds out there like her
there is hope for our future america i
love it i'm just shocked they're
everywhere and she has the money we get
to talk to them all the time they're
everywhere
god if we just have people that's smart
in congress
i mean what would we do
if you just have people you have to be
like 80 and they could take construction
like [ __ ] yeah because there's nobody in
congress can take instruction you never
got a call from a congressman or woman
yet
i'd pay good money to hear that call
we'll make it happen before you would
like if they were trying to get me to
endorse them but that was all
oh jeez
keep dreaming she's awesome what a great
young lady inspiring uh man i'm telling
you i get to talk these 20-somethings
all the time like this gives me a lot of
hope no wonder you've got a positive
outlook that's it that's it man this is
the ramsey show
[Music]
dave here we just launched a brand new
listener survey we want to know what you
think about the show you'll be entered
to win a 100 amazon gift card no
purchase necessary take the survey
ramsey solutions dot com
survey or text survey to 33 789
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice i'm dave ramsey your host thank
you for joining us america we're so glad
you're here open phones at triple eight
eight two five five two two five george
campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today as we talk to you about
your life and your money triple eight
eight two five five two two five mary is
in sunnyvale sunnyvale california hi
mary how are you
oh very good mr ramsey how are you
better than i deserve what's up in your
world
well i found your book at the local
library in july of this year and you
know i read it including rachel's book
and all that but now i'm having
like
paralysis by analysis so i don't have
any consumer loan i don't have car loans
but
i have a mortgage loan again and that's
because
i paid
off cash for my house in 2011 but then
in 2016 i refinanced it to buy a
rental
unit
and then in 2018
and i saw another opportunity so i used
my heloc plus my savings to buy another
rental
last year i got laid off
and so because of low interest rate i
refi to lower the and combine my um
to lower my mortgage and then my
key lock so i got the 1.99
interest
but i didn't know it then i didn't know
that you know i should
just pay off the house and all that but
now that i
i got laid off the recruiter of the
hospital called me back
and offering a sweet
deal
so i don't know
to pay off my mortgage should i just
sell some on my investment or should i
go back to work and pay it off and then
retire because i considered retiring
this year i mean last year
i haven't been working since last year
how old are you
uh 58 i just spent 58.
huh what are you you're a nurse
yes sir okay
is the duty hard
yeah if i go back to work i'm gonna work
my shift full time 12 hours each shift
why
why work night shift
i know because that's the only offer
they have but the hospital i'll
guarantee you there's other offers for
nurses in california
yeah but because uh if i work for the
same company i will retain my seniority
of over 25 years and investing it didn't
forget you much it got you the night
shift
yeah your seniority sucks
well um
you
you know i get i will get i will have
the first choice of vacations and all
that and then the shift that i will i
mean not the shift but like the days i
want to work but this is this is my
dilemma yeah i don't have a dilemma
you're 58 you have the money not to not
work i'm not working the night shift
that sounds strenuous to me
so tell them if they want you you'll
take the day shift with your seniority
there's none or if i want to do that i
have to work night shift first for six
months and now you're done opening no
you don't that's all it's not a law i
know it's the offer to make a
counteroffer tell them they're stupid
i'm not coming to work over there unless
you work me during the day
because that's with my own well we have
the cna contract and that gifts are
correct
so what do i do i mean i can i qualify
for pension but i haven't collected it
because once i collect this then i can
only work one day a month
or i can start collecting so when i
you know
when my goal now is to pay off so what
do you make if you what do you make if
you go back
well they will give me a sign on bonus
of thirty thousand dollars and then i'm
gonna make a hundred dollars an hour
and what does day shift pay
well
there's no position for these shifts
it's only four nights
back to where we started yeah you're you
just don't listen okay i've told you six
times there's a day position over there
you just not you just accept what they
tell you don't accept what they tell you
the rule on the ramsey show is we break
the rules
okay
so you you that listen do you understand
what you're saying they're willing to
pay you a hundred dollars an hour
and a thirty thousand dollar signing
bonus but you can't get the day shift
i'm calling bull crap on that six months
of night shifters
okay that you listen you do whatever you
wanna do hun okay
that's the deal that's there's no
possible way i'm working night shift and
if you don't understand that you are in
a cat bird seat negotiating position
here go over there and smack them
between the eyes and get the day shift
and 100 an hour and a 40 000 signing
bonus they need nurses
you are in the driver's seat
okay
quit acting like all these dadgum rules
apply they don't apply
or go to work somewhere else and let
them pay you 30 000 bucks for a day
shift but don't you don't have to go
back to the night shift make it at 58
years old when you have the opportunity
to not work anymore
i think you go back to work but i think
you go back to work in a good reasonable
situation and by definition night shift
is not that for me if i'm 58. yeah i
think she needs to advocate for herself
and she needs to do some research look
around to other companies because i
don't care about the seniority if it
means your life sucks
yeah so i mean
darwin they're putting like all these
things on the table that says they
desperately need you
and i'm trying to explain to you that
you have the power to overcome some of
what you perceive to be the rules
i don't perceive them to be the rules
and other if you don't go to work at
that hospital again doesn't matter to me
go to work at a doctor's office i don't
care but get you know if you can get 100
bucks overnight you can get 75 during
the day
and a signing bonus and you probably can
get 100 during the day right now the you
know we are in california here this is a
desperate situation and um
you know you are uh you are the hero
signing up here oh my gosh but no i'm
not gonna work six months overnight
because that's what the recruiter said
you're making more than the freaking
recruiter okay so keep in mind who's in
charge here you
all right logan is with us in milwaukee
hey logan what's up
hey um i am curious on if it's crazy for
me to consider getting uh or buying
another property when i still have a
mortgage on my first house yes
okay
short and sweet
[Laughter]
yeah i you you called the uh we believe
the shortest distance between where you
are and wealth is no debt show
right and with that it's just a long
name and so yeah it's called the other
short version is called the ramsey show
but the yeah the uh uh and so we're
always going to say clean up the debt
and then use the cash flow from your
life and from the cleaned up rental
property with no debt on it to buy the
next one and the next one the next one
i admit that that is frustrating to
start that way i can promise you when
you get to where i am i own close to 200
million in real estate all paid for
it leaves you in a different position
than my friend uh you'll be glad you did
it this way when the pandemic hits and a
bunch of your tenants
can't pay their rent
yeah and you don't have any payments
put you in a whole different world you
can be merciful
you can not go broke you can do a lot of
stuff
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
life is full of firsts
[Music]
as the first and longest serving
christian health cost sharing ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981.
we believe you should have the freedom
to focus on your health while being
supported by a community of believers
giving you the opportunity to create
many more firsts
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today we value the input of our
listeners here on the ramsey show it
helps us know what's important to you so
we can deliver the right content that
will help you with the questions and
challenges that you have right now one
way you can share your thoughts with us
is by answering a few questions in a new
survey that we just launched you can
check it out at ramseysolutions.com
survey takes only a few minutes and
there's a hundred dollar amazon gift
card that will be drawn from the people
who take the survey it's up for grabs
thanks for your time text survey to 33
789
or visit
ramseysolutions.com
survey text survey to 33789 you can take
a survey about this show and tell us
what's going on with it our question of
the day comes from blinds.com a great
american company find out for yourself
why blinds.com is the number one online
retailer of custom window coverings with
free samples free shipping and the new
promos they run all the time you save
even more use the promo code ramsay to
get the best deal today's question comes
from diane in arizona my husband and i
are in baby step two and are working
hard to pay off our debt the one issue
we struggle with is not using credit
cards we use them to pay our utilities
groceries and other monthly bills but we
never carry a balance
by doing this we're able to travel for
vacations for free using our points
what's wrong with doing this if we're
not going into more debt
the age-old question dave
the age-old question we've been
exploring this topic on the fine print
because it's one of the biggest
objections
we get uh here at ramsey are people
going well dave i pay off my card every
month i get some free stuff what's the
harm
right so we should clue in
bank of america and chase
what portion of their marketing is
working the best
and it is this crap
the vacations the points this is the one
this is the one that's got people
believing in stupidity still
after all this time yep and here's what
happens and you can listen to the the
true cost of credit card rewards this is
the second fine print episode that we
released and we dug into this with an ex
capital one insider okay what did they
say uh she said they run 10 000
experiments a year on people to figure
out what's going to get them to spend
more to use the points and one of the
biggest ways they do it is through the
points because you know how the points
work they don't say it's 500 they say
you're going to get 128 000 points that
you can use to redeem flights that cost
74 000 and the points change every day
and there's blackout dates and there's
restrictions
and on top of that uh the whole two
percent cash back that one is one of my
favorites because you know what two
percent of a thousand dollars is
twenty dolla
20 bucks to spend a thousand and uh
that's not a great deal so let me let me
get this straight if you spend ten
thousand dollars
you get 200 bucks
ding ding ding that'll make you rich
yeah spend ten thousand get two hundred
that's a formula for wealth building
right there
we did an analogy did you people go to
grade school
listen diane here's the thing we did
this analogy in the in the podcast about
chuck e cheese because this would have
reminded me of dave you go to chuck e
cheese oh my god god gives you a ten
dollar bill and you get these coins claw
on toy story yes
so you get your coins and you're so
excited to spend those coins that you
spent ten dollars on and you go and you
get all the tickets and you get 400
tickets and you go to the table at the
end of the day and you go wow i can get
any prize and they go nope you get
sticky hands and a pack of gum
and you go wow i spent ten dollars for
sticky hands and a pack of gum that cost
a quarter
yeah and i got screwed yeah i think
so uh here's the thing i don't have big
buildings dave uh the credit card
companies do they're sponsoring every
stadium in america and they're doing it
with billions of dollars that they're
making off of the backs of these people
who are overwhelming you yes yeah so
here's the thing
um
to start with you're not going on
vacation for free
that is an absolute asinine stupid
statement it is not true
you might have got your airline ticket
for free but everything else on the
vacation was not free so you're spending
money and you're going on vacation when
you should have been working because
you're in debt
you're not supposed to be going on
vacation when you're in debt
we follow everything you say no you
don't you don't go on vacation when
you're in debt and you don't go out to
eat when you're in debt you you work and
you work and you work and you clean your
dad gum dead up
and that is that that's the ramsey plan
now you can say you can you can go do
your plan if you want but don't say
you're doing my plan when you're going
on vacation because it's just not true
and here's the thing
the arrogance
that is required the intellectual
arrogance that is required for you to
think
that you are taking on
billion-dollar companies who have
algorithms that know what bottled water
you drink
and you are somehow beating them and
you're you're you're fleecing them
you're getting an airline ticket and it
doesn't cost you anything you really are
pretty arrogant
to think that you're actually winning at
this game
i mean honestly
do you understand that when when
citibank when you call them your zip
code is pulled off your nsx code and the
person answering the call if it's a
friendly call is a person of the same
accent as you
if you call from the south you'll get a
syrupy southern bell accent
and if you call from the wicked
northeast you'll get a wicked
northeastern accent
you're gonna these people screw with you
on levels you have no idea and you think
you're beating them
yeah absolutely incredible so here's the
thing we did study we did a study of
millionaires we studied 10 000 of them
10 167.
not a single one told us
we became millionaires with our free
vacation points because we ran all our
utilities our groceries and everything
else through a credit card and then we
went on vacation for free and it didn't
cost us anything and that's how we built
our wealth not one said that isn't that
odd
diane
so here's the thing
people that ask this question are people
that think they're beating the system
let me tell you how you beat the system
you don't
play don't play in the system yep you
know what it's like it's like being a
mouse in the maze and you get to the
cheese and you think i won i got the
cheese and you zoom out and you go no
i'm just a part of a giant social
experiment that exists to take my money
that's what it is
so you can play that game and that's
fine you can get your vacations but i'm
not in the in the business of trying to
gain points i'm trying to gain wealth i
want to complete the baby steps i want
to pay off my house i want to give
outrageously and that doesn't happen by
paying off my card every month and
reaping the benefits of two percent cash
back you know the chuck e cheese thing's
funny as crap oh it's great the team did
a great job with the edits we got the
coin sound
you gotta go with them out of their ski
ball or whatever they're just coming out
there like crazy you've got this long
line of tickets and your little kid they
think they're getting the big prize and
you get you never get the big price
nothing it's you got you spent 10 to 20
bucks to get a prize that cost less than
50 cents and the same thing's happening
when you go to book these flights and
you go well we can go to boise
yeah i don't think uh martinique was on
the list was it no you're not going to
the bahamas first class i'm sorry so
belize and bermuda are not on the list
no no
so san diego's nonetheless nashville's
not on the list no it's blackout
blackout dates blackout mean they don't
go don't oh no they just won't take you
that's what it means i i think you can
do a lot better by using a debit card
and using cash and saving up for your
own dang vacations yeah you know where i
go on vacation anywhere you want there
you go
that's how that works and you know when
i use those credit cards that that
always works so that's how it happens i
haven't had a credit card and my gosh
it's george it's coming up on 30 years
wow we should have a party we should we
can't use points to pay for the party
though in belize in police
i'm in how about cabo let's go to cabo
i'm in we're heading there man i'm
telling you i love it great question
diane uh but a heart a hard answer yeah
well
because it's passive aggressive so you
need a wrong answer i mean yeah what's
wrong with doing this because we're not
going into any more debt yes you are
you're going into debt because you're
not paying off the debt that you have
because you're spending money that you
don't have to do crap you shouldn't do
there's a just there it is
it's a simple thing but it's your life
darling you get to do what you want to
do the problem is you ask our opinion
and we are an expert on our opinion
and we've led more people out of debt
and into wealth than any other brand in
america today
but you do what you want to do kiddo
this you be you this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
george camel ramsey personality is my
co-host today augustine is with us he's
in uh
coeur d'alene idaho hi augustine how are
you
good how are you better than i deserve
what's up
so i'm 21 and i bought a house this
january before i turned 21 because i
really wanted to like that was my goal
in high school
and uh so i did it but now work has been
really up and down
and so every once in a while like i'll
have a trouble making the payments so i
want to make extra cash rather than just
working
but the house has made about a hundred
thousand dollars in equity in the last
seven months so my question is
should i sell it and have more to put
down on a regular down payment like a
bigger down payment on a different house
or
like use it as an airbnb style
or something else like that
[Music]
what do you do for a living
i work on elevators
what's your extra job
um i my second i was working at a um at
a marina for a second job when it was
slow
now works then works picking back up so
i'm i'm making
i make 38 an hour right now
at the elevator job which is like it's a
good job but it's just kind of sketchy
so i was just curious
[Music]
what do you mean by sketchy as far as
yeah it's volatile it says it's
considered construction work
it goes up and down with the amount of
work that we're able to pull in
so when work is good like when we have a
lot of um
big jobs or whatnot work is great and i
can't complain and payments are super
easy and i have no struggles but when
it's slow like when
like we finish a big job and it's like
slow for a month or so and it's like
okay well now what now
i really it comes i think comes down to
a budgeting question but
i think it comes down to a career
question
because you're never going to be able to
establish a life with a income that is
not that is not steady enough
that you can you know make enough money
during the year to eat
right sure because here's the thing if
it doesn't matter if you have some down
if you have some months that the income
disappears
uh as long as you have enough months
that it doesn't and the overall
average for the year is still an
excellent income i mean if you make 500
000 a year
you don't but if you make 500 000 a year
and you have two months with no income
it's not a big deal
right right so the point is you're not
making any money
it's not just the volatility it's the
overall income is not enough to support
you
they're not working you enough to where
at the end of the year when you add it
up you had a good job
that's what i'm saying
so i think you got a career problem i
think you got a house problem
you may need to sell your house to step
into your next career or you may need to
look for a different place to
apply your trade
um
because you you know 38 bucks an hour is
pretty sweet income
uh but not if you're not getting it
right
so
because i mean
if you're 31 you don't need to be making
the same phone call with the same income
problem agreed
agreed agreed so that you got to solve
the career problem and then that'll tell
you what to do with the house no you
don't do airbnb
you either get this career thing solved
and keep the house or you sell the house
put the money in the bank until you get
the career thing solved one of those two
things but the last thing you need some
other goob living in your house you know
you're trying to pay payments and maybe
they don't show up because of covid
and you know maybe idaho decides to lose
its dad gum mine like some of these
other places and now you're just shut
down and you don't need all this risk
man you're 21 you got 100 000 bucks on
the table take your money and run
sit over there in an apartment and get
yourself solved or get yourself solved
and keep the house one of the twos what
i would do yeah we need some stability
here and a financial foundation i don't
know if you have any debt but if you do
sell the house i want you to make sure
you're following the baby steps you
clean up the debt you have an emergency
fund that way when you get into a house
again you're not gonna be having this
problem where you're having anxiety
about being able to afford the payment
in case something goes bad in case you
know you can't find some work but i do
think you need to find a career that's
stable with a steady paycheck right now
at your age yeah
it is a bit um i had trouble not
laughing
his income goes up and down in the
elevator business okay i'm just saying i
missed that that was way over my head
i'm just i just yeah that was straight
yeah that's no that's clever yeah that's
well it is what happened i mean
that's the business it goes up
that's a papa dave joke right there
oh okay
eric is in washington dc hey eric what's
up
hey dave i'm still laughing from that
last call he enjoyed it okay good we got
another one all right good
how can we help i am uh so i'm calling
because i want your career advice i'm
sort of at an impasse right now i
currently work a salaried position and i
was offered recently a 100 commission
job
okay what do you make of the salary
i make 80 000 what do you do
i am a real estate evaluation consultant
at a large firm
so you're doing it you're doing internal
appraisals for their purchases
uh so i work with internal and external
clients and it's valuation work for
different commercial real estate assets
but some of it is appraisals okay all
right so some of it's for depreciation
schedules and so forth yep that's
correct gotcha okay we use some of those
firms here okay cool uh 80 grand how old
are you
i'm
and your strike commission gig is what
this would be in the real estate
industry as well would be for financial
brokerage
for commercial real estate
financial brokerage
right so i would connect borrowers and
lenders for
these large commercial assets okay and
that's what the income would come from
is those those success fees so a
commercial originator of sorts okay
um
you probably have pretty good knowledge
of that business why what what
what is uh what do you think your income
would be have you talked to other people
doing it that are
have you know have you got some kind of
trend line on this thing
yeah i mean i've interviewed people in
the industry and it's really just a
success or failure sort of thing it's
like the matthew effect either you get
it all or you don't get anything
so it's pretty risky in my opinion and
that's sort of why i'm calling up i
don't have any debt i have you know some
savings in the bank but i don't want to
just give that away for this risk
um but you know it's all dependent on
the individual
well and the market can shift on you and
mess you up too so um
you know hey
i mean what would you think you know
i mean i i don't know how to project
this is this a two hundred thousand
dollar thing is this a hundred thousand
dollar thing what are you thinking
you know there have been guys that they
make two deals a year and they make a
quarter of a million dollars but then
others struggle to you know live off of
ten deals yeah i'm lucky that i can live
off of you know 50 grand obviously way
more than that in my you know i don't
know any kids
relatively young
but
becoming a new i don't have any
connections which is what the name of
the game is and that's where you're
going to make the big bucks so starting
out i would probably struggle what's an
is there an interim step a middle step
or you don't have to jump all the way in
the deep end of the pool
no i'm well that's yeah i know that's
that's why it's a difficult decision for
me there's no there's no salaried you
know no i'm not talking about salary i'm
talking about is there an apprenticeship
or is there could you go sell commercial
real estate for a while and build the
connections
so i would currently i would work under
two directors and so i would get their
mentorship so i would not be there you
know just you know by myself in the deep
end i would have connections
guiding me
and they might throw you some of the
crumbs off their table
exactly okay
i guess i'd add up the crumbs and see
what they look like and can i make it on
that for a year or two and give this a
good hard try it sounds like a wonderful
adventure the the upside is that there's
a tremendous income potential the
downside is is the slice of the market
that you're operating in is really thin
the number of human beings and the
number of actual deals that will need
you
is a small number compared to say
things where there are large numbers
like residential real estate you do
bazillion houses right this is a small
number of humans ever do a transaction
or even witness a transaction like
you're doing
um but when you hit one i mean you're
whale hunting you're elephant hunting
you're not rabbit hunting there's you
know when you go elephant hunting
there's just a few of them but they're
really big and rabbits they're
everywhere you know and so
that that's kind of what you're looking
at i don't know what to tell you it
sounds kind of interesting except it
just bothers me that the slice is so
thin yeah he's young if he has the risk
tolerance it's an adventure just have a
big old savings account he does have the
risk tolerance from hearing his voice
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture today proverbs 12 25
anxiety weighs down the heart
but a kind word
cheers it up
maya angelou said if you must look back
do so forgivingly
if you must look forward do so
prayerfully
however the wisest thing you can do is
be present in the present
gratefully
go maya
some classics all right kelsey is with
us in baltimore maryland kelsey how can
george campbell and i help
hi guys i'm so excited to be talking to
you you too um
so i have a question about whole life
insurance um my parents got a policy for
me when i was
in the crib
and um passed this policy on to me a few
years ago
we used we took a loan out from it to
put down on the house and
you know just kind of knowing we never
had to pay it back
and
just knowing that i didn't really care
about this policy it's very small we
have other life insurance that's not
whole
um
i'm not sure what to do on you know to
keep it active i pay about
800 900 a year um and
literally cancelling what about the tax
implications don't worry about that at
all there aren't any oh here's why okay
your tax basis
in a whole life policy is the total of
the premiums paid in
there is no possible way
that you took out of this policy more
than your parents has paid in
yeah they're just they're just horrible
it's it's a black hole for money
especially kid whole life policies your
parents meant well they were really
sweet and the net result was they were
able to help you with the down payment
on a house had they actually invested in
the mutual fund with the same amount of
money they put in this policy they could
have just bought you a house but that's
a side issue
that's open that's water under the
bridge now so that's how bad these
things are mathematically
so but anyway yeah you don't keep it
around no it's not a pet and
we can honor their intent and their
heart without uh you know continuing to
throw money
off the bridge every day every month
every year right
so yeah i would just if you don't need
the life insurance i just cancel it
um if the basis does come in and they
will send it to you because they'll
threaten you with this it's their way of
getting you to not cancel it apparently
that's already happened that's where you
got this information
the agent says oh no you're going to get
taxed and you're like yeah it's four
dollars you know but uh
instead of 800 this year so i i can i
i'm going to give you a 95 probability
that there's no taxes on it at all
on the five percent chance that there is
there your taxes will be less than your
premium this year
okay
so i mean at the end of the day when you
get get it all done it's not gonna
you're cause you're again your basis
is the total of the premiums paid in
and only if you receive more than that
including the loaned amount okay because
the loan is
is paid off as a part of the uh the
cancellation and if there's anything
above the loan that comes to you those
two things if that is larger than the
total of the premiums only then will
there be taxes and it almost never is
because these things really suck so bad
right okay great thank you so much steve
thank you for the call
appreciate you joining us
you know so
that is like a
product from the 1940s and 1950s it's
like a uh
it's like an alligator it's a dinosaur
that has survived into the modern era
how do they do that
marketing it's a dinosaur because
when you sell it
people buy it whatever it is if you sell
it enough aggressively enough people buy
it um i mean gerber
the baby food company still sells whole
life policies wow to people when they
get a baby so that they can go to
college well let me tell you where
you're going to college
nowhere
not with that you're not getting in
anywhere with that policy yeah okay
because you're going to make 14 when
it's all over you're getting screwed
no
listen if you buy your financial
products from a baby food company it
might be an issue wrong
okay if your baby food says
american funds on the outside of it you
might have the wrong baby food come on
don't eat it stay in your lane people
stay in your lane and you talk about why
this is a bad product it's trying to do
two things at once it's trying to be
insurance and an investment and you're
saying hey there's way better always
only one and you're always paying for
both yep that's the problem so we
recommend uh term life insurance level
term life 15 to 20-year policy to where
you're self-insured when that policy
runs out and that's the production of
the price that's for adults yeah and if
you want to save money for your kids
save money for your kids but there's no
need for a mutual fund a life insurance
policy you know life insurance policy on
a kid because if they pass away you
didn't lose their income now if they get
a two million dollar uh ad campaign
contract with huggies
because they have a cute butt
that's great then sign up a life
insurance policy because now you have an
income there for this cute butt yeah and
you've got to take you know you got to
protect that but that's
99 of the children do not make a income
that's worth insuring okay
so you know this is just and so it's
being used as a savings vehicle for
college and that's a freaking joke
so what happened was her parents paid
into it their whole her whole life 20
years and she got five or 10 grand out
of it it's the sun cost fallacy i got to
keep this thing alive because we've been
keeping it alive forever yep
it's the sacred cow we've always done it
this way and this is why we will always
continue to do it this way we have no
other reasoning
that's it the batteries it's a sacred
cow rule yeah brian's with us brian is
in columbus georgia hi brian how are you
good well dave how are you better than i
deserve what's up
so my wife and i are both active duty
arby we've been in the army for about
eight years
we both plan on serving and retiring
after 20 years
my question is about the best way to
save and be to be financially
independent at 42
obviously we'll we'll still do something
but you know after working as hard as we
have over the last eight years or so we
like to be able to you know volunteer
take care of the family uh do whatever
so without being able to have access to
traditional retirement savings venues
curious if you have any thoughts on that
well you have a roth ira is available to
you and you have the tsp available to
you
so we're currently saving in in both of
those uh but i just didn't want to incur
oh yeah yeah oh i see what you're saying
you need some bridge money you need some
other money outside of that okay
yeah exactly so thank you for your
service by the way so you got 12 years
to roll and get ready yep how much is in
your tsp and roths now
so right now we have about 150 between
our roth iras and roth tsps okay you'll
be at about 600 with that plus whatever
you put in
so we we make about 150 after tax right
now
we also have about 120 in non-retirement
investment accounts
um some of that we have set aside the
you know by buying you buy a new car in
like two years um
and when miles give out yeah you're
still gonna have a million to a million
and a half
at your current rate uh plus whatever
you put in so you're you're in really
good shape um
if you're invested in in you know market
rates of return in good mutual funds
that's where you'll roll on that
so um
yeah i think i think you got to look at
some low turnover mutual funds they're
called get with one of our smart vester
pros and just set up a whole side thing
that says okay i need this amount of
money and let's say you build 600k in
there
and uh 500k in there and you won't pull
10 off of it that's going to give you
50k plus your double military retirement
you ought to be fine
okay and on top of that you're gonna
have another million dollars but that's
all trapped until 59 and a half
and on top of that you're only freaking
42 and you probably do need to go do
something and make some money
just for just for fun how would you uh
how would you oh absolutely how would
you allocate i guess before saying
saving 15
um a year would you shift the
um i think you have a more aggressive
plan than a 15 plan number one i want
you to get the house paid for but aside
from that you may want to put as soon as
you get the house paid for you can go
more than 15
and i'm going to go i'm going to go
pretty heavy over into that bridge
because you're going to have
i mean you're rocking it you're doing a
great job i'm gonna head over into that
bridge a low turnover mutual fund is a
mutual fund that doesn't have what about
five percent or less of the taxes uh are
due on the gains because they're not
selling the stocks inside the mutual
fund so that's what you're looking for
low turnover ratio mutual fund
it'll keep the taxes off of you until
you actually use the money like a
capital gains rate it's a it's a really
good strategy for what you're trying to
do
[Music]
george campbell good job thank you ben
and kelly be back before you know it in
the meantime remember there's ultimately
only one way to financial peace and
that's to walk daily with the prince of
peace christ jesus
dave here we just launched a brand new
listener survey we want to know what you
think about the show you'll be entered
to win a 100 amazon gift card no
purchase necessary take the survey at
ramseysolutions.com
survey or text survey to 33 789
[Music]
you